[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Hi
there, Heather again.
JENNY BROWN: And hello
again from me, Jenny.
I'm a sales trainer
for Google Cloud.
HEATHER CROSS: Users expect
apps to be available 24/7,
and developers also expect
to be able to deploy
new versions of their
app multiple times a day.
On today's episode, we'll
introduce Google Kubernetes
engine.
JENNY BROWN: We'll also
run through a quick demo
of the self-paced
lab where we'll
deploy a containerized
application with Kubernetes
engine.
Let's get started.
HEATHER CROSS: As
a starting point,
let's take a moment to
discuss containers as well
as Kubernetes.
JENNY BROWN: Absolutely.
So containers
address the problem
of how to easily and
consistently deploy
apps in different environments.
They essentially allow
apps to be broken down
into smaller independent pieces
that can be deployed or managed
dynamically.
Containerization also
allows a separation
of apps from
infrastructure, which
is going to allow developers
to focus on their apps
while IT operations
teams can focus
on deployment and management.
And because containers
are so lightweight,
individual services
can quickly be
called when they're
needed and are
available almost immediately.
HEATHER CROSS: Which
brings us to Kubernetes.
Is a production
ready open source
platform and provides a
container centric management
environment.
So instead of having
all of your applications
separate from your
libraries and your kernel,
each application has its
own library associated
with it resting above a kernel.
Kubernetes allows you to
interact with your container
cluster to deploy
and manage your apps,
perform administration tasks
and set policies, and monitor
the health of your
deployed workloads.
JENNY BROWN: Google
Kubernetes engine
is the premier managed
Kubernetes solution.
Leveraging Google's
infrastructure,
Kubernetes engine provides
the perfect manage environment
for deploying,
managing, and scaling
your containerized apps.
HEATHER CROSS: Simply
described, the compute, memory,
and storage resources your
application containers require,
Kubernetes engine will provision
and manage the underlying Cloud
resources automatically.
JENNY BROWN: Google also wants
to ensure that your users have
a seamless experience.
So Google Site Reliability
engineers, or SREs,
constantly monitor your
cluster and its resources
to ensure that your services
are highly available.
Kubernetes engine
auto-scaling will also
allow you to handle any
increased demand while
scaling back during
those quieter periods.
HEATHER CROSS: From Gmail
to YouTube to search,
everything at Google
runs on containers.
Google Kubernetes engine
allows you to benefit from all
that we've learned the last
decade on building container
management systems.
JENNY BROWN: Time
again for Qwiklabs.
This hands-on lab, which
will take about 30 minutes
to complete, shows
you how to deploy
a containerized application
with Kubernetes engine.
You can check out the link
to start the quick lab here.
At this point in the lab, you've
created a Kubernetes engine
cluster and authenticated
for the cluster.
To deploy a containerized
application,
you'll create a new deployment
from the hello app container
image.
You'll then create a
Kubernetes service,
which is a resource that lets
you expose your application
to external traffic.
Once deployed, you can
inspect the deployed service.
You can then view the
deployed application
from your web browser
using the external IP
address with the exposed port.
HEATHER CROSS: Well,
there we have it.
We hope you enjoyed
this episode and would
love to hear more about how
you would use Google Kubernetes
engine.
JENNY BROWN: Don't
forget to keep
visiting our OnAir
webinar series, Qwiklabs,
and our blogs.
All the links are below.
HEATHER CROSS:
You can also learn
more about Kubernetes engine
through our on-demand courses
on Coursera.
Thanks for watching
and we'll see you soon.
JENNY BROWN: Last week, we
reviewed Google App Engine
so that you can focus on
watching your app and not
the development platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]